hey youtubers is Charlie so this week
for my Game of Thrones bonus video I
wanted to talk about my favorite
character pairings one of the few good
things about the show being different
from the books is that you just get to
spend more time with really interesting
characters it's true you could argue
that some of the characters that they
cut are just as interesting as the
characters that they live in but the
benefit is is that you know you do fall
in love with some of the characters that
they have on the show and you get to
spend more time with them so this is
gonna be my top 5 character pairings
from the show oh and a new round of the
book giveaway starts right now all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment but careful for
spoilers from everything through seasons
4 I'll wait just a sec ok everybody
ready here we go number 5 jaime and
cersei i always love watching interviews
where people asked lena headey and
Nikolaj coster-waldau about Jaime and
Cersei motivations sometimes you just
catch them looking off into the distance
and you're not sure whether or not they
just hate answering Jaime Cersei
questions or if they're not really sure
I think it's a little bit of both Jaime
and Cersei are one of those couples
that's just so wrong that it's right
they along with most of the other people
on this list or tailor-made for tumblr
and no matter what ends up happening in
future seasons I don't think that either
one of them is ever going to be able to
completely unwind their relationship
like they're fundamentally linked
they're twins they share genetic
material even if they didn't have a
sexual relationship they would still
have that pseudo psychic shared twin
space in their heads but they would
still constantly be thinking about each
other
I know that everyone was a little bit
upset with what they did with Jaime's
character especially with that big Jaime
Cersei scene and Baelor except it did
seem like he had been on something of a
redemptive art and back slit big time
with the twincest over their dead son's
body I don't think it would have been
very interesting if Jamie had
automatically turned into a boy scout
during the back half of season 3 you
know not that that possibility is
completely gone I do still believe that
he's gonna try to find some sort of
redemption whether or not he actually
achieves that part of me just feels like
everyone in that family is doomed you
know best of intentions they're still
going to be doomed regardless of what
happens to either one of those
characters in the future their
relationship is part of the bedrock of
the series it's implied that Jaime's
character is going in a different
direction on the show than it is in the
book so I'm interested to see if George
R Barton backtracks any or
both characters end up in the same place
I think that's the idea like even if the
show does different things different
scenes I think both of the characters
are going to end up in the same place
number 4 John and Ygritte they spent a
lot of time together in the book so I
was a little disappointed that Egrets
teachings didn't become as big a thing
on the show in the books it just seemed
like she was much more of a guide to
John than she was on the show but I
think that's just a function of the
amount of time that they could have them
on screen like there are a lot of
characters they have to service them all
so you can't spend all of your time with
just two people I know they made John's
sexual education a really big thing but
their relationship went way deeper than
that John had like this really rapid
period of mind expansion whenever he was
north of the wall with her if you look
at it from like a hero's journey Joseph
Campbell perspective Ygritte was like
his goddess she imparted great wisdom
sensual wisdom yes but also a lot of
cultural wisdom it's like being a
foreign exchange student and coming home
to the realization that you only learned
a fraction of the real truth of the
world in your primary school sometimes I
like to think about them climbing the
wall in season 3 is like this crazy drug
trip that they did together like they
both dropped ecstasy and their journey
up the wall was just a process of the
drugs opening John's mind just as you
hit the top you get that big wide shot
south of the wall BAM
John comes to this huge realization he
is just a small man in the grand scale
of the universe to be fair though I
think all the cave sex and Ygritte dying
opened John's mind in that way too
now the Egrets gone or physically gone I
mean she's never gonna completely be
gone from John's head I'll be interested
to see if John Melisandre becomes the
next season I feel like that long look
over the fire was a big teaser for some
amazing scenes with them next year I
don't think they're gonna take it to a
sexual place like D'Andra Melisandre but
still something is gonna happen with
those two which actually leads me to
number 3 Stannis and Melisandre I always
feel like the red woman's playing games
with everyone so even though she and
Stannis have a very toxic Jaime Cersei
type relationship - the twincest Stannis
is always going to be the subordinate in
their relationship I mean let's be
honest about who the real brains of the
operation are I feel like he's
completely at her mercy and he just
isn't willing to say it out loud
Jaime and Cersei are a little bit more
balanced in their relationship
Stannis always seemed to me like he was
ridden so that you would not
for him a key is always automatically
going to be the lesser person whenever
two people are standing around with them
sometimes I actually get the sense in
the narrative that he feels that way
about himself and it just makes him
really really mad like that's why he's
so mad it's just because he senses that
everyone doesn't like him that might be
one of the reasons why he took up with
Melisandre so willingly he just reeks of
desperation and neediness which are two
of the most unattractive qualities in a
person
so naturally whenever they're standing
around you're always going to be rooting
for Melisandre to do something crazy to
him speaking of wanting something crazy
to happen number two Jaime and Brienne
probably one of my favorite tragic
couples on TV right now just two people
that seem like they bring out so much
potential in each other but because it's
part in writing the story you get the
sense that they're never gonna get any
kind of happy ending like there's no
Disney ending for anyone in A Song of
Ice and Fire but definitely not for
Jaime and Brienne that's not necessarily
a bad thing I think knowing that they're
probably never going to consummate their
relationship makes their scenes a little
more electric and if you absolutely have
to take it to that place there is a ton
of tumblr fan fiction that will go there
sometimes I feel like the show has paid
a lot of fanservice just because they've
kept Bri on a lot more than she is in
the books
her character changes are actually some
of the ones that I'm a little bit more
happy with I mean she's a really
interesting character but she's one of
so many in the books that you just do
not spend as much time with her there's
also that giant plot line that they got
rid of when they didn't do Lady
Stoneheart in season 4 so I'm curious to
see if they continue to go in a
different direction with Jaime and
Brienne or if they circle back around to
the book story at some point in some
creative way like sometimes whenever
they change things on the show like the
whole brand Karl Tanner storyline in
season 4 they still go in the same
direction like bran still ended up
meeting the Bloodraven
I'm actually starting to wonder if we're
gonna see any crossover with the Sansa
bran storyline that would be a big
departure from the books - I do not
think the brand's gonna head right back
to King's Landing
even though Arya Stark slipped through
her fingers I mean she still feels like
Sansa is out there somewhere which
actually leads me to my number 1 pairing
Arya Stark and the Hound team the
king for all the changes the show made
to the books in season 4
I felt like Arya and the Hound stayed
pretty close to the books for the most
part there were a lot of minor details
that were off like the timing and the
cause of their split but arias still
came to the
same conclusion she just stopped giving
a about him I think part of the
reason why I like those two characters
together so much is just because there's
such an odd couple but they bring out
the best in each other already learned
where the heart is which is actually a
good metaphor for growing up and the
Hound found something that made him feel
like less of a dirtbag like he actually
grew as a character quite a bit too
even though it didn't seem that way I
mean ultimately he never really crossed
that bridge so to speak like he didn't
evolve like Aria did which is probably
why she had to leave him I know there
are a lot of grave digger theories out
there so he might still be alive and get
a measure of redemption but at least he
did help Aria evolve in season four I
think - my favorite scenes with them
together were when Aria made both of her
kills whenever she killed Pulver and
then Rory I don't think she would have
been able to do that without the hounds
influence I know based on the way they
left things at the end of the season
there's all kinds of talk going on it's
important to note that Aria didn't
really think that the Hound was dead
whenever she left she just left him to
his fate and walked off so I don't think
that she thinks that he's dead I think
she just doesn't care that essentially
means that he's still on her list she
didn't cross him off so someday if they
do cross paths again she will kill him
but it's totally possible that they
could do a Gendry thing where the Hound
just does not appear in season five at
all
Rory McCann has not been spotted on set
an aria is filming in a completely
different location let me know though
who is your favorite pairing on the show
and who's your favorite pairing in the
books if it's a different pair just a
quick reminder to the world of Ice and
Fire book is coming out at the end of
the mode so in about two weeks what I'm
gonna do for my giveaway is just make it
four copies of that it is going to be a
badass book so I encourage all of you
guys to buy a hardback copy that
actually reminds me congratulations to
this week's giveaway winner
Edward fall you basically win your
choice of any of Martin's books so I'll
reach out to your channel for details
lots of other really big stuff happening
tonight the flash episode 1 premieres
and then airs tomorrow so be sure to
check those out my next game of Thrones
video is probably gonna be a theory
video there's just a whole lot of
theories that I haven't spent a lot of
time talking about and it's totally
interesting if there's any theories in
particular that you guys really want to
talk about just let me know in the
comments but right now click here for my
top 5 prophecies on the show not quite
the same thing as theories and click
here for my top 10
characters that I want to see come back
to life thank you so much for watching
so let's all high-five I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]